We've got blood tests,
we've got nasal swabs,
all kinds of ways to
detect the coronavirus,
and now we can add to that mix, poop,
specifically, wastewater.
There's a company called Biobot
that's analyzing this wastewater
to try and look for the coronavirus.
And they've found that in a lot of cases,
the virus is much more widespread
than the more conventional
test would show.
So let's head off to Massachusetts
to interview the founders of Biobot.
Would you two mind introducing yourselves,
maybe Mariana first?
My name is Mariana Matus.
I am co-founder and CEO
of Biobot Analytics.
My name is Newsha Ghaeli,
and I am co-founder and
president at Biobot Analytics.
Your company, the two of you have come up
with a pretty unique way
to look at the coronavirus.
I mean, you're talking about sewage
coming from different parts
of the country, right?
Correct.
We can detect the virus in wastewater
because people who are infected
shed the virus in stool,
and it makes its way into the
wastewater infrastructure.
Then wastewater treatment
plants collect samples
and send them to us.
Right now, Biobot has a pro bono campaign,
and we are testing about
10% of the US population
on a weekly basis, versus
about 1% of the US population
that is being tested through the clinics.
And the results that you've already seen
are pretty striking.
Yeah.
Our first results were gathered
from a large metropolitan
region in Massachusetts.
And on the day that the
samples were collected,
there were about 450
confirmed clinical cases
in that community.
And what we were able to
see via sewage testing
is that there were up to 100,000 people
infected with coronavirus
in that catchment area.
So just dramatically more
than what the regular tests were showing?
Yeah, exactly.
There's actually a large
asymptomatic population, likely,
or individuals who have
very mild symptoms.
and so they're not seeking out testing.
However, they're captured and
represented in sewage data,
and so we're seeing them in our tests.
And I know you get a 50-milliliter sample.
How is that representative of
an entire city's population?
So, treatment plants,
they can sample the wastewater
as it comes into the
treatment plant constantly
through 24 hours to guarantee
that we get representation
from every toilet flush that
went through that community.
And then from that aggregate sample,
they are taking a small
aliquot and sending that to us.
And using that sample,
we measure how much virus
was present in the wastewater
with a technique called QPCR,
that looks for the genetic
signature of the virus.
Okay.
And you'd already had this
company up and running
to look for other, what,
other diseases in wastewater already?
Correct.
We originally were working
with the opioid epidemic,
measuring the concentration
of different types
of prescription opioids in wastewater
to create better programs.
It's not the most glamorous job, maybe.
What drew you to this field?
I really grew up with hardship,
so I've always been passionate
about creating technologies
that help with equity and
just bringing better resources
to people who need it.
And the beauty of looking at
wastewater as a diagnostic
is that everybody has
a voice in the sewer.
You don't need to have the
money to go to the doctor.
You don't need to have medical insurance.
As long as your house is
connected to the wastewater,
your information is counted,
and we can bring that to
create better programming.
What's your vision for how this plays out
over the coming years?
Yeah, our vision is that
one day this technology
will be basic infrastructure
for every city
and town worldwide.
So we will be constantly
screening our populations
for new outbreaks of
the novel coronavirus.
And in this next week,
two weeks, three weeks,
there's just going to
be more and more data
coming out, obviously,
from the work you're doing.
All of the facilities
that we're working with
really believe that weekly
testing is very important.
One of the biggest
questions facing government
and decision makers
right now is how and when
can we start to safely
open up our cities again
and our economies again,
and testing at scale is one
of the most critical things
in order to help us get there.
And we're not going to be able to test
every single individual;
that's just not realistic.
And so, this type of testing
can really be helpful
in making these types of decisions
of scaling back quarantine-style measures
or social distancing.
And so, all of the facilities
that we're working with
are sending us weekly samples,
we're giving weekly data back to them,
and, yeah, we're excited
to see how that progresses.